I have cerebral palsy which is a
neurological disorder also it's a
traumatic brain injury that happens
either in utero during the birthing
process or within the first couple of
months of life so a 26 year old can't
get cerebral palsy it's not genetic you
can't catch it even though I have seen
people become a bit more spilly around
me it's not contagious I promise my
cerebral palsy happened during birth the
doctor who delivered me was drunk and I
came out fist first ready to fight the
power and he panicked and cut my mom six
different times in six different
directions and as a result I lost oxygen
that loss of oxygen damaged the part of
my brain that handles coordination and
as a result I shake all the time now
it's really important to remember
cerebral palsy is a spectrum so
different people with CP have different
symptoms they have different abilities
some people use wheelchairs some people
are mobile some are verbal some are
nonverbal that doesn't mean that we're
intellectually superior in any way to
our counterparts who have less or more
ability but cerebral palsy can also
happen alongside other disabilities so
there are people with CP and mental
illness there are people with CP and you
know respiratory problems and there are
people like me who just have CP and I
work really hard to keep my health up
and I think that having a disability is
often thought of as like this poor
person and she's always struggling and I
don't really think of my CP that way I
think of it as part of me it doesn't
define me there are days where I hate it
and there are days where I don't even
think about it I'm a person who watches
TV all the time all the time I love TV
and I really think that the media
heavily influences how we as a society
behave towards each other and one of the
things that I find to
lacking on television are positive
images of diversity Hollywood talks a
lot about diversity and I think that the
definition is wrong it's not about
having you know one person of this color
and one person of this gender and one
person of this it's about actually
including those people and allowing them
to tell their stories and creating
images that mirror those in the real
world and one of the places that I feel
this is the most necessary is with
people with disabilities people with
disabilities are the largest minority in
the world we cross all races classes
religion gender we're the minority group
that you can join when you don't want to
at any time in your life and we are the
most underrepresented on media and
television and when you do see
disability on television
we're reduced to two story lines either
heal me or you can't love me because I'm
disabled we're never full-fledged
characters that fall in love maybe have
kids maybe get in a catfight
you know we're reduced to these
snowflake angel eternal children and the
fact that people with disabilities grow
up and that we're functioning members of
society and that we're not just here to
bleed the system is not something I see
on TV in addition to the hot roles of
people with disability are often played
by actors who do not have those
disabilities and those actors often take
home awards meanwhile the disabled
community is watching this and to us it
looks like a caricature because we don't
believe that visible disability is
something that you can act we feel like
it's something more like race where yes
there's a visible component but there's
also an internalization that an actor
that's just mimicking twitches is not
capturing so we're shut out from playing
the wacky best friend when there's no
reason that we should be but we're also
shut out from playing the roles of
actual people with disabilities I
believe that the reason I encountered so
much
hate after my first big TV appearance on
countdown with Keith Oberman was because
people are not used to seeing disability
on TV so they thought it was okay to
guess what I had I was there to talk
about politics we did not address my
disability and when I went home and
googled myself like any egomaniacal
actress with a dream does I saw people
saying it's Botox gone wrong it's bad
surgery she's drunk she's drunk she's
Muslim maybe her husband beat her and my
favorite one poor Gumby mouth terrorist
we should probably pray for her so I
felt like if people were more exposed to
positive images of disability to
characters like a radar from mash who
we're just there and we're great and
we're part of the system or if one of
the girlfriends on Big Bang Theory are a
gladiator on scandal was the wheelchair
user or had cerebral palsy or was
actually blind that people would then
consider us as equals but right now
we're plot devices and where are these
horrible news packages that you see on
my Good Morning America these
inspirational stories that really
dehumanize us because it's like aren't
you surprised this person wasn't
disability was able to tie their shoes
and that's a big accomplishment for a
lot of people and I'm not downplaying
that but at the same time why don't you
ever see the lawyers the doctors the
wives the mothers you never see those
images when you're being exposed to
disability on television
you